So let's have a quiz and a programming exercise on this.
Here, we've given you the code that you just saw.
Now, what I want you do to is modify the code to time several different scenarios, okay?
So try running a million threads, each incrementing one of a million elements,
so every thread is uniquely incrementing a single element,
a million threads atomically incrementing a million elements,
a million threads incrementing a hundred elements, or a million threads
atomically incrementing a hundred elements, or finally, 10 million threads
atomically incrementing a hundred elements.
And for each of these choices, I'm going to want you to tell me 2 things.
First of all, does it give the correct answer? Put a check mark by those that give the correct answer.
And second of all, rank them from fastest to slowest,
so the fastest will be 1, the slowest will be 5.